good morning uncle Hank it's Monday yeah
Henry and he shown the puffs oh very
puffy
so I he'll never guess where I'm going
this morning unless you guess the
dentist this seems like good weather for
vlog driving sewing the other day I saw
this tweet from Amanda Bynes right Hank
so now that I'm home with my mouth hurts
it belatedly occurs to me that among
your abundant charms is that you can
probably name all six types of quarks
but probably don't know who Amanda Bynes
is look Hank he's already reading
reading pictures amanda Bynes is an
American movie actress who i apparently
follow on twitter yes i am ashamed so
the other day amanda Bynes tweets I hate
it when people say I said things I
didn't say stop putting words in my
mouth then less than 24 hours later she
tweets your imagination is your preview
of life's coming attractions Albert
Einstein and Hank in that tweet Amanda
Bynes committed the most common sin on
the Internet confusing your and your
know exposing yourself on chatroulette
no misquoting Albert Einstein much to my
continuing annoyance the internet fails
to appreciate the fact that Albert
Einstein was a physicist not a quotation
generation machine so less than 24 hours
after amanda Bynes complains that she's
being misquoted all of the time she
misquote someone else people who make
their lives public will be misquoted and
if they don't like that they should make
their lives private and that's reason
one of three why you won't see a ton of
your nephew Henry in the forthcoming
video blogs I mean it's not like you're
gonna see none of them but I want the
choice of whether he has a private life
to be his also number two Hank I don't
know if this happened to you but when I
was in high school whenever I would take
a girlfriend home to meet mom what am I
saying I don't know if this happened to
you of course it didn't happen you
didn't have any girlfriends in high
school the first thing mom did was pull
out a photo album of baby pictures and
she would bring the girl over and she
would literally be like look at that
little baby wasn't he cute look at his
tiny little penis
I'm telling you when he came out of my
body I said are you sure that's a boy
meanwhile in the background I'd be like
hi
Moody this is John Green I'm gonna need
a disillusionment charm ASAP anachronism
what anachronism there were no
disillusionment charms when you were in
high school Harry Potter hadn't been
published
you're an anachronism version of me
talking to me from a slightly different
angle so ink I don't want to tell
embarrassing stories about Henry that
instead of reaching an audience of one
girlfriend reach an audience of like you
know Lots right so the reason number
three Hank you are a nerdfighter and I
am a nerdfighter and nerdfighters you
are nerdfighters but not everyone
watching this video is a nerdfighter you
know how I know Hank because sometimes
we get YouTube messages like this one
which I swear I am NOT making up I'm not
going to tell you his username I assume
it's a him so that you don't spam him
hello hi friend please upload hot videos
like kisses and other also please upload
hot videos about animals okay hmm
okay isn't the first adjective that
comes to mind Hank the funny thing about
this message is not that its sender
wants us to upload hot videos like
kisses and other the funniest thing to
me is that this YouTube user appears to
be under the impression that there are
currently an inadequate number of videos
on YouTube featuring kisses and other
and he thinks the only way to rectify
this problem is to reach out to the
vlogbrothers Hank
call me crazy but I don't want that guy
seeing too much of your nephew Hank
Henry is awesome he loves his aunt
Katherine's quilt thank you for the
video you made thank you to Maureen for
being actual John Green so actually
nerdfighters thanks for everything we
love you guys so much if you have any
questions about the baby I'll try to
answer them in comments Hank I'll see
you on Wednesday
Shh Henry is sleeping like a champion